- Who has spoken at our conference
on several previous occasions.
He's, are you chair of
orthopedic surgery at Rady?
Program director at
Rady Children's Hospital
in San Diego and professor of
clinical orthopedic surgery
at UC San Diego.
And the David Sutherland director
of the cerebral palsy program at Rady.
And program director of the
education program there.
You're one of the original
Botox investigators,
and overseeing a movement disorder clinic,
as well as a lifespan
disability clinic since 1992.
And your son, who has cerebral
palsy, is now 35 years old.
Wow.
Welcome back.
- Thank you so much, thanks.
Thanks for having me back.
It's always an honor to come
to this great conference.
Yesterday I flew in from
the American Academy
of Orthopedic Surgery
meeting in New Orleans.
And we were learning how to put the screws
in the right place and all that stuff,
and I walked into the transgender talk.
I guess I'm not in Kansas anymore, Toto.
This is a different group of people.
When I was a visiting professor
in Melbourne, Australia,
I was challenged by my host
to give a more personal talk
than rather a technical talk.
And so I'm going to talk a
little bit about our family
and how it affected me and
how it affected the way
I think about cerebral palsy.
How many people in here
have family members
or themselves have some sort
of developmental disability?
And the rest of you when
into it for the big money?
OK, all right, great.
Is this the advance, I'm sorry.
Oh here it is.
All right, so I'm going to
talk about cerebral palsy,
a view from both sides.
And these are my disclosures.
I'm not going to talk too much about it,
but there are some off-label use.
Botulinum toxin, at least
some of the ones like Botox
that you've heard of,
has not been approved for
use in spasticity by the FDA.
Dysport however recently was approved
for lower-extremity spasticity.
I talk about intrathecal baclofen,
it's not approved for the use in dystonia,
and it's the best thing
you can do for dystonia.
However, when you think about it,
50% of all the drugs that we
use as pediatric specialists
are not approved for use in children.
So we do these things
off-label all the time.
Every day you do that.
What is cerebral palsy?
And there's a lot of
different definitions.
When I was a resident I was taught
that it was all due to obstetrical trauma.
And as you all know, if you
go google cerebral palsy now,
you'll find all the best, they're
actually pretty good sites
but they're all lawyer sites.
And they have good pictures,
and tell you how to sue your doctor,
sue your obstetrician.
Was the baby too big or too small?
And one of the things that
as we get together as a group
and come up with consensus
we feel that it occurs
before the age of three.
I can't believe I'm talking
in front of Marshalyn,
and she's going to tell me
everything I'm doing is wrong.
The world's best epidemiologist.
So I'll probably misquote her
several times in this talk.
And then this is a thing that our academy,
American Academy of Cerebral Palsy
and Developmental Medicine
came up with a definition.
And really, you all know
what cerebral palsy is
so I don't have to go into much detail,
but that it's a non-progressive
disturbance of the brain.
And I may argue a little bit against that
from some of the things that
I've seen in my adult practice,
but it affects everything.
So, I'm not going to read
that whole definition,
but it affects everything in the body.
So, epidemiology, and
you notice I call this
the cerebral palsies,
there's no such thing
as cerebral palsy, there's no one disease
or one entity.
And some of this work is
from Eve Blair in Australia.
And so the risk is much higher
if you're born prematurely.
If you're very small.
And one in three children
with very low birth weight
will have CP.
However, as you saw today
from Yvonne's slides,
most of the children with
cerebral palsy are not premature.
It's maybe a little bit more than half.
And you can see that number there.
The prevalence, and this
is from Marshalyn's study,
showed that in three states,
that prevalence is a little bit higher
than we have been talking
about, one to three,
and now it's it's probably
three to four patients,
3.8 was the number.
And so there are about 10,000
new diagnoses each year.
About a million people
in the United States
have cerebral palsy.
One of the things is
we've been more successful
in the NICU and also
taking care of children
as pediatricians, is that we
have a longer survival rate.
And there are now more adults
than there are children
with cerebral palsy.
There's also some racial differences,
which we aren't really
quite sure why that is,
it probably has to do with
availability of services
in the prenatal period.
But 54% of Americans have
some sort of disability.
In fact everyone in this room,
at some point in your life,
will be either disabled or dead.
Think about that.
Right?
You're gonna be in a walker or crutches
or a walker or something or a wheelchair.
Or you're gonna be dead.
If you look at the entire cost
of a child with cerebral palsy
across all levels of severity
it's about a million dollars,
so it's a huge impact
on our medical system.
The etiology of the cerebral palsies.
I'm not going to go through all these.
Mainly it just shows you how
complex cerebral palsy is,
and that there are so
many different types.
The thing that I'm just
going to, once again,
because I'm bringing a little
bit of my family into it,
and that is this hemostatic disorders.
So we talked a little bit in the EPO talk
about how it can cause
increased clotting problems.
My wife was pregnant when I was an intern.
And we found out we were gonna have twins.
About halfway through my internship
one of our twins died in utero.
And when he was born, I mean
when my other son was born,
prematurely because my
wife had an abruption,
we found out that the other
child's umbilical cord
was completely clotted off.
And that was the cause.
We go that's really terrible, bad luck,
and my son has really
bad, GMFCS level 4 CP now.
And then 20 years later my
wife got several blood clots
coming back from a from
a trip over to Europe
where we sat on the
ground for a long time.
And turns out that she
has Factor V Leiden.
The heterozygous type,
not the homozygous type.
But if you think about it,
about up to 5% of American women
have this as maybe a cause
of seizure disorders.
Not seizure disorders,
but stroke problems.
And so that's where we found
out where my son had this.
There are some other
interesting things in here,
and Yvonne talked about these
as far as chromosomal
and brain abnormalities.
Many of our GMFCS level 5 patients,
the more severely involved patients,
have some sort of chromosomal abnormality.
We just got a $120 million
grant at Rady Children's
in San Diego and we're
doing more genetic testing
on all these patients
and we're finding things
that you've never even heard of.
It's just a series of numbers
and then I'm supposed to
figure out what to do with that child.
And I think I'm glad I'm
at the end of my career
rather than the beginning of my career,
because I don't know how
we're ever going to know
how to to treat these
because we won't know
the natural history.
A big study here in Contra Costa County
several years ago demonstrated
that there is an increased
incidence of vaginosis
in the mothers whose
children had cerebral palsy.
And once again, none of these things are,
these are correlations,
they're not causations.
And we really aren't sure what's going on.
We do know that some things
like epigenetic factors,
such as maternal depression,
that's misspelled,
and a couple of other
things that are happening.
So just think about the brain
and remember the homunculus
from medical school and from college.
And think about why does this happen.
Well now you're gonna hear
the simple orthopedic surgeon,
there's no neurology going on here,
this is orthopedic
surgeons with pictures, OK?
So it's the only way
I can remember things.
Here's the brain, that
kind of looks like a brain.
And here's the homunculus.
And remember this gyrus
here is where the legs are.
And your legs are pretty
stupid, they do the same thing.
You walk, they don't do
anything fancy with that.
With your hands and your face
you have a lot of
different things going on.
So these are the ventricles,
and then remember
this watershed area,
and that was a thing
that Yvonne talked about.
If there's a area of injury right there,
the legs are more preferentially involved
than the upper extremities.
And that's what diplegia
means, the lower extremities
are involved more in
the upper extremities.
And it can be symmetric,
but most of time it's not.
And very rarely are two kids the same.
And it's really hard for
us to do research now
because we don't know, we
can't get a control group
because they're not the same,
they have some other problem going on.
And she talked about the strokes.
And then this area, the basal ganglia,
our understanding of what
happens at the basal ganglia
has really changed our evaluation
of children with cerebral palsy,
our treatment of children
with cerebral palsy.
And I'll explain that as
later as we get to that.
This new functional MRI
information is just beautiful,
it looks great, we don't
know what to do with it yet.
There's so many, you
know, there's all these,
all it does is show how
interconnected the brain is.
I mean that's the most important thing.
If you look at some of
these tractography things.
There's, something come
from the cerebellum happens,
goes to almost everything every tract
that comes out of your body.
So if you have a problem
in your cerebellum
it affects your balance,
it affects everything,
it affects your speech, it
affects the way you walk,
it affects the way you talk.
The way you use your upper extremities.
And so we're learning
this, but this becomes
very complex, three-dimensional things.
So, Yvonne talked a little bit
about some of these preventive strategies,
and obviously that's going to be our hope
is to not have a child
with cerebral palsy.
As you can see, we could talk an hour
about every single one of these things.
And she talked about some of those.
I think most of us believe
that this is an inflammatory problem,
particularly in the premature children,
and and maybe in the HIE patients.
And so what can we do, what
kind of anti-inflammatories
are we're gonna be able to to give,
whether that's cooling or
EPO, all kinds of things.
There are some children that
are born with hypothyroidism.
It has to be tested or you
won't be able to treat it.
And that's an effect on the brain.
We talked about EPO and other things
that are erythropoiesis
stimulating agents.
Avoidance, having mothers
avoid toxic substances
of course is important.
Assistive reproductive
technology has changed.
So probably 10 or 15 years ago
we would have runs of
quadruplets and quintuplets
from this reproductive technology,
and I think the obstetricians
are much better at it now.
So they might be able to implant
at least at the most twins.
And so our incidence went down.
At one point we had six
quintuplet sets in our NICUs.
Of all of those, two of
them had cerebral palsy.
So I'm still taking care
of those those families.
And of course remember I told you
cerebral palsy goes up
to the age of three,
so anything you can do to
prevent non-accidental trauma,
near-drowning and those things
that cause brain injuries,
it's very similar to cerebral palsy.
So how did I get into this field?
When I was in medical school
I was very interested in pediatrics,
I thought that was what I was going to do.
Then I got very interested in orthopedics.
And then I found out
there's a thing called
pediatric orthopedics.
So that's what I was gonna do
when I started medical school.
When I started my residency.
So this is before my son was born.
But we were going by,
my wife was pregnant,
and we saw a United
Cerebral Palsy telethon.
And she goes, what's cerebral palsy?
And I go, oh let's see, I
learned that in that same class
where I learned about muscular dystrophy,
and myasthenia gravis, and
so I made up something.
And in my pediatric rotation
I only had one patient
with cerebral palsy the whole
two months I was on that
as an intern.
And then when my son was
born, when I was an intern,
and this is him, and he weighed
two pounds and nine ounces.
My residency taught me
everything that is wrong.
And unfortunately I
still see this going on
across the world and
across the United States.
We just lengthen tendons.
Orthopedic surgeons just lengthen tendons
and see how they do.
Put them in casts for a long time.
And that's what I learned,
and that's what my son had.
He had all these surgeries, my
son's had 29 operations now.
And I would say 20 of them were bad.
And I pushed them, so that
makes me feel even worse.
I was very fortunate to do
a fellowship at San Diego
with Dr. David Sutherland,
who became famous here at UCSF
and at the Shriners Hospital.
He was one of the inventors
of the field of gait analysis.
And was a very forward thinker
in the way that we do surgery.
And so it was very lucky.
And the other thing is, for
those of you who are younger
and are getting into this field,
I think it's very important
to get into one of the organizations.
And so I started off
in the American Academy of Cerebral Palsy.
Went to meetings, got to meet
everybody, got on committees,
eventually was the president
of the organization.
And right now I can call
anybody in the world
if I have a question.
And those things are really important.
And unfortunately my inbox
is filled with people
asking me questions right now.
But it also is great.
It's a good thing.
So what is gait analysis,
I mentioned that because
of Dr. Sutherland.
This is really an important field.
So as I told you every child is different.
And so there's different
ways to do gait analysis,
you can do, I can just watch
a child walk back and forth,
write down my observations.
I can take a video on
my iPhone and save that.
My hospital won't let me do that,
but my iPhone's filled with them.
And the other thing is to do what's called
three-dimensional gait analysis,
where you can measure what's
going on in three dimensions
and then make your
decisions based on that.
Those of you have never seen gait analysis
might have seen some movies
where gait analysis was used.
Like every Pixar movie,
every Disney movie was
made with gait analysis.
Steven Spielberg sent
his team down to our lab
for three weeks and we
showed them motion capture,
and how that works.
And we go, oh man we're
going to get research money,
this is going to be great.
And we took them out to dinner,
we did all kinds of stuff.
And then they ended up saying thank you,
and then they went and bought
20 motion capture systems.
And that's when they started
making the Pixar movies.
So we got nothing out of it.
But I do enjoy those movies,
so I guess that's good.
Classification systems.
The diplegia, quadriplegia,
hemiplegia system
has very poor intra- and
inter-observer reliability.
If you look at my own chart,
some day I'll say the
kid has severe diplegia
and the next day he has
a mild quadriplegia.
And so it's really hard
to, these don't work.
You know one of the people that,
a famous neurologist who popularized this,
he didn't come up with it
but he popularized this.
Anybody know?
Sigmund Freud.
So Sigmund Freud, one of his
big interests in research
was cerebral palsy.
He wasn't a psychiatrist
he was a neurologist.
There's a thing in Europe where
they talk about unilateral
versus bilateral.
Talk about simplistic,
I really don't like this system at all.
It doesn't make any sense.
Anybody who's taken care
of a kid with hemiplegia
knows that they're not unilateral.
And now there's been
many studies that showed
that that's wrong 25% of the time.
So that's not a very good
system, I don't think.
Using this household
ambulator, therapy ambulator,
community ambulator,
those are good things.
Kind of gives you a
picture of the patient,
but it doesn't tell you much about it.
And what's revolutionized
the field of cerebral palsy
is the Gross Motor Functional
Classification System.
And this is derived from
a test called the GMFM.
Many of you are therapists
and know how to do this.
It takes a while, you have
to ask a lot of questions,
you do tests, and you
come up with a score.
A number, and you take that number,
and a group in Canada just
started putting these out
and plotting these hundreds of patients.
And realized that they came out in five
pretty close groups.
And came up with something
really complicated
of how to figure out what they are,
and of course orthopedic
surgeons get ahold of it
and make pictures and make cartoons.
And so this these cartoons are great
because that's how I remember it.
And hopefully the way
you'll remember it too.
So a level one patient
is someone who hardly has
anything wrong with them.
They may be a little bit uncoordinated.
Might be the last kid
picked on the baseball team.
There's just something different.
A level two is someone who
has problems on uneven ground,
and in a first world
country the way you can tell
is they're wearing an AFO, OK.
That doesn't work so much in
Haiti, where I go, or Jamaica.
But if they have an AFO that
tells you they have GMFCS 2.
A level three is someone who
uses crutches or a walker.
Can push themselves in
a regular wheelchair,
but usually a walker.
Level four is someone
who's in a powered chair,
or someone who can walk in therapy.
And then a level five is someone
whose needs complete care,
and is in a wheelchair most of the time.
And so this is really
an interesting thing,
because if you just use
the word spastic diplegia,
that could be almost this entire group.
It could be anywhere on there.
I have about 20 papers that
I just need to throw away
that I wrote, because I used, in fact,
the first of our Botox
patients were all GMFCS 1s.
So here's the interesting
thing about this,
is if you do anything to a child
before the age of six or seven, anything,
physical therapy, early
intervention, Botox, any surgery,
they're getting better,
that's the natural history.
They're going to improve
no matter what you do.
So all the kids in the first Botox studies
were under the age of six and GMFCS 1.
And surprisingly they all got better,
what a miracle, a miracle
drug, I'm such a great doctor.
But anyways, so when we look at the GMFCS
and how it revolutionized things,
everything that we do is
almost directly correlated.
It's not even logarithmically,
it's directly correlated
to their GMFCS.
And these are the things
that we do in orthopedics.
Including things like
morbidity and mortality.
The GMFCS is not an outcome measure,
it's just a classification system.
But if you want to do something
to see if you can improve
what they're doing in the
gross motor functional area,
it's to do this thing called
the functional mobility scale.
And that's what the child
can do at five meters,
50 meters, and 500 meters.
And you figure that out and you can say
that by doing this
intervention they improved
from using a wheelchair at 50 meters,
and they're now using a walker.
So that's something that you've done
to improve their outcomes.
Now there are other,
that's just the gross motor
functional classification,
we also have, I had nothing to do with it,
but people have developed
scales for the upper extremity
called the Manual Ability
Classification System.
Very similar.
There's now a communication system.
So this is really a
great way to communicate,
and also for us to do research.
So if you tell me this
person is a GMFCS level 3,
and then you tell me
what they do at 5 meters,
50 meters, 500 meters,
you tell me how they use
their upper extremities
based on this, and you tell
me how they communicate,
I have a great picture of
that person in my mind.
And also if I'm doing research,
I go, I want all those
patients to be in that group.
And so it really has changed our field.
Very simple thing.
Now we talk about the
dimensions of disability,
and you saw some of this yesterday.
And all of you are familiar with these,
but the the International Classification
of Functioning, Disability,
and Health, or the ICF,
looks at body functions and structures,
activities and participation,
and environmental factors.
And so this is the model
that we base all of our research on.
And also what our goals are
as taking care of children
and adults with disabilities.
So I can work a little
bit on body and function
and structures, my goal is to
get them to participate more,
and then I have almost nothing to do
with environmental factors,
that's usually something
that the government does
with the curb cuts, and
accommodations at work.
I started this when I was in San Antonio,
as a junior faculty member,
and I started the Challenger
baseball league there.
And I also started the
Challenger league in San Diego.
And so this is a baseball
thing where the kids come out
and this is my son Shawn
and his little brother.
And this is him just last week.
He's in a drumming circle.
You can just see the joy that he has.
And so that's our goal,
is to get your patients
and your son and everybody
out, doing stuff.
I wish he was that happy all the time,
that's a different story,
we'll talk about that later.
The other one is, this
is actually my favorite.
It was made by the NIH and it's NCMRR.
And it puts a person
at the center of this.
It could be anybody,
it doesn't have to be,
when I give this talk to
the orthopedic residents
I say this could be
someone with a hip problem
that you're going to do a total hip on.
And looks at the different
dimensions of that problem.
And it looks at the
pathophysiology, what caused it,
we talked a little bit about it.
What's the impairment,
which means what's
happening at the cell level,
for example spasticity.
How do we treat that.
We look at the functional limitation,
those are the, what does
spasticity do for you,
if you're walking, you
have a hard time walking,
you have a hard time speaking,
you have a hard time using
your upper extremities.
Your disability, or what
are your roles in society.
We all have different roles.
We're students, teachers, husbands, wives.
Think of every role that you have.
How does that disability impact those.
And then the societal limitations
are what does our society
put in as far as way of curb
cuts and attitudinal approach,
problems of the way we treat
people with disabilities.
As we learned yesterday in the ACLU talk.
This was kind of thrown out mainly
because almost all the words are negative.
You know, disability, functional
limitation, impairment.
And that's where the WHO came out of that
with positive language.
Just because it's negative
doesn't mean it's not good,
so I like it and it helps me
think about different things.
So we come up with different paradigms.
And we all have to set goals.
And it's really important that these goals
are collective and realistic.
So when you sit down
with a family to decide
whether it's therapy or some drug,
Botox, orthopedic surgery.
I'm not going to cure your
child's cerebral palsy,
and if that's what you think your goal is
then no one's going to be happy.
And so we have to set the goals.
We have a team.
You all are this team.
My first thing I did in the CP Academy,
this is like 1991 or something,
they asked me to put on the Family Forum,
which is the first one that we had.
And so I brought all the
people who were specialists
to come and speak to the
audience in San Diego.
And I stupidly put 32 people on the stage,
because that's how many people impact,
you know if you think
about speech therapists,
physical therapists, gastroenterologists.
It was a great one, we
never replicated that
because it was just ridiculous.
And then the management
of movement disorders,
we'll talk about that.
And the different therapies.
What's the role of technology.
Most important thing of
course, orthopedic surgery.
Not really, it's the
least important thing.
And then we'll talk about that.
So we have to set goals.
And this is a study that
was done about 20 years ago.
The question was, this
is asked of young adults,
what's the most important
thing in your life?
The first one was independence.
And I think that's true of all of us,
who wants to be living with their parents,
you want to be independent.
The next one was to have a job.
In of my earlier slides I
showed you that 75% of people
with cerebral palsy are unemployed
even if they have skills.
Communication, just what we're doing now,
just talking, exchanging ideas.
Activities of daily living,
brushing your teeth,
going to the bathroom,
just taking care of yourself.
Mobility, getting from point
A to point B, very important.
And the least important of all, drum roll,
was walking, which is what I do all day,
trying to get people to walk.
And so we're actually
doing a study right now
where we're asking the
parents the similar thing.
I haven't looked at the
data yet, but my guess is
it's going to be completely
opposite of this, right?
The first one, all they
care about is walking.
I went through that, when
my son couldn't walk.
That's one of the things you give up.
I mean it's really a horrible thing
when you realize your child can't walk.
So, you go backwards, and the
last thing anybody cares about
is independence.
As we learned yesterday
in conservatorship.
Or guardianship, if you're
not from this state.
So we have an integrated approach
for children with cerebral palsy.
I'm obviously not going to
go through all of these,
but it's important it's just a big team,
that we work together, and
come up with the answers.
So a lot of you here,
I know, are therapists.
So occupational therapists,
at least in the field of cerebral palsy,
are the ones that take
care of upper extremity
and oral motor problems.
Talking, to you, it's a joke,
but I give this talk
to orthopedic surgeons.
Speech and language is very important.
The management of drooling.
So this is a kind of an interesting,
you know the kids who
are GMFCS 3, 4s, and 5s
often have drooling.
Does anybody know which federal agency
has spent the most money
on drooling research?
See, you're not supposed to answer it.
(laughing)
It's actually, it's NASA.
You usually get Department of Defense,
or now, the White House.
(audience applauding)
Actually that's us watching TV at night,
going seriously?
But when you go into space, you drool.
It just goes all over the place.
I've actually been to two
NASA drooling seminars.
And the story they told me,
because my son had a real
bad drooling problem.
When Gemini, you know we had Mercury,
they went up and they came down.
Gemini, for the young people
who don't know anything about this,
that's when they sent two people up
and they stayed up for a long
time, like several weeks.
Not knowing that when they
took their helmets off
this drool just came
out all over the place.
They didn't know, they didn't see it.
Except for as soon as they
came back in the atmosphere
it came all over their masks,
and just two weeks of drool
all over everything.
And so now they have ways to stop that.
In fact the first thing they have to do
on the space shuttle is
wake up in the morning
with a little vacuum cleaner
and find the little drool
things and pick them up.
Because it can get in the
instruments and short it out.
The other thing that we
don't think about is,
this is a brain injury, so
there's visual problems.
And if you think about, we
have a child with hemiplegia,
just close one eye and see,
when you bring your other hand over,
when do you actually see it.
It's pretty far, it's almost
midline before you see it.
So if you have this kid
that you're working on,
you go, why aren't you using your hand?
He doesn't even know he has a hand.
And so that's a real problem,
besides the fact that there's
a motor disorder there.
They forget that they have the hand.
And the other one is you
can have a field cut,
inferior field cut, so if you're walking,
you can't see the floor,
you're going to have
really hard time walking.
So physical therapy,
there's a lot of different
physical therapies,
we can talk an hour on each
of the different things.
Everyone in this room of course
knows what hippotherapy is,
none of the orthopedic surgeons do.
Even though the picture's right there.
And those glasses now are back in style.
Although women wear them I saw
them on the plane yesterday.
So just know that they're back.
And the other thing
that physical therapists
I think are really great
at is managing equipment.
Those of you are therapists know that.
You know the equipment
much better than we do.
And what will be helpful for them.
So that brings up the field of technology.
There's a promise and challenges.
A lot of people say if we
just gave a lot of money
to technology and threw everything to it,
then things would be great.
However there's a lot of
challenges with technology.
It's very expensive, these
things can't be mass-produced.
There's not that many
people that need them,
so it becomes very expensive.
Training is really hard.
So my son had the DynaVox,
do you all use the DynaVox,
remember using the DynaVox?
I could never figure that thing out,
it's like you have to have
like a PhD in communication.
Anyways, I'll talk about that in a second,
but there's training
and then there's upkeep,
you have to upgrade it, things break,
and of course the insurance company
might pay for the first one
but they won't pay to fix it,
as you all know.
And many times we have to do
specificity for each child,
and then you as therapists know
that, that that's your job,
to keep that going.
Some say what if we have
robotics, wouldn't that be cool,
we could do really cool
things with robotics.
And maybe there may be
something in the future.
And this is the Lokomat, many
of you have seen these before,
they cost a million
dollars each, at least.
And so we're using them
for kids who are GMFCS 4.
So the kids who are really non-ambulators,
and maybe the GMFCS 3 kids.
I'm not putting it down,
because I think it's good
to get exercise and things,
but is it really going to
change that person's life?
Are they really going to go from a GMFCS 4
to a GMFCS 3, that's very
rare for that to happen.
Our goal as clinicians is to keep someone
in their GMFCS level, so
if you see someone dropping
from a three to four,
your goal is to get them
back to the three, and
that could be from surgery
or physical therapy or something.
Your goal is not to make them
go from a three to a two.
That just doesn't happen.
Maybe occasionally, but
it doesn't usually happen.
However, this one right here,
using a child that has athetosis,
and using a computer to modulate
those extra movements so
they can use a computer,
those are going to be very helpful.
So I think there's a lot of
things that are coming along.
Speech therapy and communication devices.
You all know how important this is,
I told you where it was in
people's hierarchy of needs.
So we went from this DynaVox,
which cost like $8,000,
I had one, which we never used.
And then all these very simple ones.
One of my friends, well
our friend Richard Ellison,
in New York, sold his,
he had the Leapfrog or something,
he sold that to DynaVox, but
he was smart enough to know
that the market was about to crash.
Because no one at DynaVox had
heard of an iPad, apparently.
And so he made millions of dollars,
and then they went bankrupt
like, a couple months later.
So he's very smart.
But this is where we
are now, a iPad's $500,
and you can get the,
it's usually about a $400
application to put on it.
And so we've had really
good luck with that,
and the speech is very good.
Mobility is getting
from point A to point B,
and this usually just
means different types
of assistive devices.
And it also shows how bad
public transportation is
for people with disabilities.
At least in San Diego.
I can't speak for everywhere,
but almost everywhere I give
this talk, they all agree,
it's really hard to get
on public transportation.
This is a controversial area.
Especially as I'm talking to
room with therapists in it,
so I have to remember
what I'm talking about.
So a lot of people, everybody
wants to get people standing.
And their goal is to
improve a lot of things,
bone-density, GI function,
urologic function,
there's all kinds of
good reasons to stand.
And I agree with that.
However when the studies were
actually done with DEXA scans
and things at Boston Children's,
you have to stand for at
least an hour half a day
to get any improvement in your bones.
That's a lot, an hour
and a half a day's a lot.
And no one knows if it affects,
they don't have a long-term,
they don't know if it affects
fracture or fragility.
And if you look at how some of these kids,
particular the GMFCS 4
and 5 kids are standing,
they're standing on their groin,
there's no weight going
through those legs.
So the area in your pelvis
is probably pretty good.
That area never breaks.
But you just wonder,
when I tell us someone,
when they want to go onto
a standing program, I
ask them do they like it.
And if the kid likes it, and
they like to do things upright,
I think that's really good.
Because I take care of adults,
and I still had some people
that were taking four other
adults to lift this person
into a standing frame every
day, and the person hated it.
Because they said well,
it's gonna affect his bones,
he's gonna break his bones if we don't.
And I don't think there's any evidence
that shows that that's true.
Wheelchairs, we go from
the simple sling chairs
to the custom power chairs.
Don't ever use those for
anything but transportation.
Any of the sling chairs,
I mean have you sat
in one of those chairs,
you know the ones they take
you out of the hospital with?
If you sit on those for
more than like an hour,
your legs numb, and they're
not very comfortable.
But it becomes very expensive,
and we go the way up
to these very expensive things.
I know you all know this
because you work in the field.
How much do these cost?
Yeah, my son's cost 35,000, the last one.
Be he has to tilt in space
because he has GI problems,
and so it just becomes
very very expensive,
if you think about that.
Transportation, there's
not very many of these,
this is from Columbus, Ohio.
These are very expensive.
I'm on our fourth one of those,
how much do those cost?
Yeah, after the van after it's converted,
it's 50, yeah 45 to 50.
If you get an FM radio
in it, it's like 40, 50.
So they're very expensive
and that's the problem.
Most of our families can't afford this.
I'm an orthopedic
surgeon, I can afford it,
but it's not readily
available to everyone.
When you can get them used
that means they're almost worn out.
The shocks are bad, everything's bad,
because you had all that extra weight.
So we talk about the medical
management of cerebral palsy,
and it's not just the motor problems,
all those things we talked about before.
And I just list all of these things here
because my son's had all of those.
And unfortunately I had to
diagnose most of them myself,
because no one picked them up,
particularly the the gall stones
and the the kidney stones were missed.
So we talked about movement disorders,
and the importance of how we treat these.
What is spasticity?
Know the definition of spasticity<
You all treat it every day, what is it?
Do you guys know what you're treating?
(laughing)
What is the definition of spasticity?
Yeah, that's not it, actually.
Yes sir?
Yeah, that's not it either.
Yes?
Yes, it's the reaction of a
muscle to a rapid stretch.
To a rapid movement.
What you're talking about is dystonia,
and I'll talk about that in just a second.
And what's the best way to test it?
Big hint's on the board.
That's how you rapidly stretch a muscle,
you'd hit the tendon and you stretch it.
And that's how that's how it works.
Choreo-athetosis what is that?
Oh come on, this group,
I can, there you go.
All right there you got
it, you got it back there.
It's the marionette
movement, and that's great,
so that's very good, I appreciate that.
How about ataxia, how do you
know if someone is ataxic.
So every time you either walk
with a really broad base,
or every time you walk,
the next step is different
from the one before it.
I know none of you have ever
seen anybody drink alcohol,
but if you have, that's what
ataxia looks like afterwards.
So it's every step, maybe you
might have had alcohol before.
I just came from the American
Academy of Orthopedic Surgeons
in New Orleans, I saw a
lot of ataxia come in.
Fact my son, who's now a
chief resident in orthopedics
at the Cleveland Clinic came
in at 2:00 in the morning
yesterday, quite ataxic.
And then dystonia is
what you were talking,
dystonia is the posturing,
you get your muscle
in a different position and
you posture and turn the head,
you see this in the kids.
And this is a really critical thing,
and it changes how we take care of kids.
When I give this talk
to orthopedic surgeons
I go, why do we care
about any of this stuff,
this is what neurologists do.
But if you have a child that has dystonia,
the worst thing you could
possibly do for that kid
is to do an orthopedic surgery on them
to lengthen their tendons.
You'll make them much worse.
My son has dystonia.
And the other thing about
dystonia is it doesn't show up
until they're about
six or seven years old.
They're not born with dystonia,
and then it gets worse during puberty.
And so you might miss it.
And we sometimes do
surgery on little kids,
and then you screw them up.
So I would say 10 of my
son's surgeries were wrong
because he has dystonia.
Including the selective dorsal rhizotomy.
So this is just a bigger picture.
And this is really for the
stupid orthopedic surgery,
but hopefully you guys will
pick something up out of it.
So if you all were to cut your head off,
you would just be a reflex.
As you walk you would
rapidly stretch your gastroc,
it would go back.
That's your stretch
receptors and your muscle,
it would go back through your spinal cord
and right away you'd pop
back up on your toes.
And that's what equinus is.
So a kid with equinus is doing that.
What comes from the brain are inhibitors
or modulators of that reflex.
And that drug, or that
neurotransmitter, is GABA.
Gamma-aminobutyric acid.
So what do we do, what
are things that we give
that are GABA-agonists.
Valium, baclofen, those are
those are GABA-agonists.
What can we do in this
to stop this reflex arc?
We put botulinum toxin into the muscle,
that stops this thing.
We can do selective dorsal rhizotomies,
and that's all to break
up this reflex arc.
So this really simple idea
explains how all of our
treatments of spasticity works.
Just based on this.
If you remember that spasticity
is the rapid stretch.
So here's a child with ataxia.
Just to show the movements.
You can see its wide base,
sometimes they're different.
Here's a child with choreo-athetosis.
I think you can see how she
has a hard time walking.
Here's a child that has both
dystonia and choreo-athetosis.
So there's the movement
and you'll see his arm
just kind of go into full extension there,
and just keep his arm stiff.
And that's the dystonia part.
So this really changed our field
of understanding spasticity
versus dystonia.
And so when you tell me a
child has spastic quadriplegia,
that's probably not true.
There's spasticity there,
but most of them have
dystonic cerebral palsy.
And that's a huge difference.
And this is a picture
of my son when he was,
this is in his baseball league
and actually that person
is his roommate today.
They're now 35 and 37 years old.
And then this was him he was
so rotated from his dystonia
he couldn't use his computer anymore.
He couldn't drive his wheelchair
and he asked me at this age
to take him to the
operating room and kill him.
His life was so miserable.
And so this comes down to this area,
it's called the basal ganglia.
And of course as an orthopedic surgeon
I will spend an hour
explaining these to you,
I have no idea what they are,
but they're somewhere down in the brain.
But there are other problems
that happen with cerebral palsy
that we forget about is the
loss of selective motor control.
So two children, they
look exactly the same,
they the same amount of spasticity,
but if you ask them to reach for something
and grab it they can't.
And the one that's the most common
is someone that has hemiplegia
that has a drop foot afterwards.
They can't fire their tib-ant,
even though they have a tib-ant.
The tibialis anterior muscle.
We forget the sensory deficits
that happen with strokes
for kids with hemiplegia,
they may not feel their upper extremity,
they may not feel their legs.
And then last is weakness,
and we really didn't
appreciate how weak children
with cerebral palsy were weak
until we were able to
manage their spasticity.
You can stand up a kid with
spasticity and dystonia,
and they just stand there and go,
look how strong that kid is.
And then you manage that
and they're just as a weak
as you possibly can be.
And so what do we do with physical therapy
and managing spasticity.
We can do physical
therapy and those of you
who've had a massage
know exactly how you feel
for about 15 minutes afterwards,
and go why did I spend that much money,
it was great but now I feel tight again.
And then these are the drugs that we use.
So we use diazepam, we use baclofen,
and for kids who have
dystonia we can use this drug
called artane.
I haven't had good success with it,
but there are some people that use it
for all their children with dystonia.
The big problem that I've seen with this
is really severe nightmares.
So the kids just want to quit taking it
because their nightmares are so bad.
We can put phenol or
alcohol right on the nerve,
and that dissolves the myelin sheath,
and that breaks up once
again that reflex arc.
And then we can use the botulinum toxins,
once again are off-label,
but I've given over 20,000 injections now.
And now I have six
physiatrists that work with me,
and that's much of what they do.
And this new thing, this cannabis CBD oil,
I think there's really some hope for that.
I have some families who are using that.
And the problem is is we can't study it.
Jeff Sessions said he
would put me in jail.
And really my hospital won't let me do it
because we're worried we're
gonna lose our federal funding
if we study it so I can't
I can't even study it.
So it's really really kind of sad.
I can prescribe it but I can't use it.
So in orthopedic surgery
we can lengthen tendons,
that lengthens that reflex arc,
it changes that reflex arc.
But it only lasts for about six months.
We can actually cut the
bones to rotate them,
that lengthens some muscles
and shorten some muscles.
We can cut nerves which
we never like to do
because they often come back
and it doesn't work very well.
And surprisingly if you fuse
the spine in some of these kids
who have really bad
dystonia and athetosis,
it improves them.
We don't know why, there's
some central control of that,
and I think that's why.
The big thing that's changed our care
particularly of dystonia is
the intrathecal baclofen pump.
That's where we place
the pump in the muscles
underneath in the abdomen,
run a tube around the back
and into the spine.
And you can run it all the way up.
If you want to get the upper extremities
you put it up there, if
you want to get both,
if you want to get upper and
lower, if you just need lower
you do there.
My son had the highest one put
in at the time, it's at C2,
and really changed his
life in several ways.
It got rid of his dystonia completely.
He has none.
He's floppy now, which is
great to help take care of him.
But he still has motor control.
The bad thing is it
affected his swallowing,
and he got pneumonia
which put him in the ICU
for six months.
And he had to have a feeding tube placed,
and so those things are all
things you don't think about,
but in retrospect if we ever lost this,
his quality of life would be so bad.
You can do a selective dorsal rhizotomy.
So these are these are kids where you cut
some of the afferent neurons
that go back to the spine.
That breaks up the reflex arc.
You cut about 30 to 40% from L1 to S1,
and you improve, or from L2 to S1,
and it decreases their spasticity.
However, these are only for
kids who are pure spasticity,
premature, have good trunk control,
and are probably level ones or two.
They don't work for everything else.
Of course my son's of
four, he had a rhizotomy,
and because of that he had
horrible lordosis of the spine.
I'll show you his
picture of what happened,
and actually had spine fractures
from being in this lordosis.
So another unintended
consequence made by your father.
So this is him before the surgery
and then after the surgery.
And you can tell how that
baclofen pump helped.
Deep brain stimulation seems like could be
a really positive thing.
The center of research in
this area is here at UCSF,
and my patients that get
the come up here for that.
And it hasn't worked so
well in cerebral palsy
because there's such a diffuse injury.
It has worked well in kids who have
what's called DYT1 dystonia,
which looks like cerebral palsy
but it's an inherited problem.
So in orthopedic surgery
we want to do things called
single event multi-level surgery
where we do as many operations
as we can on one day.
So I'll sometimes do 20
operations on one day on one kid.
And then they go through all the rehab,
and all the pain's out of the way.
We use epidural catheters,
and then they start the rehab period.
And that's a new change
and there are still
places in the world that don't do that.
You want to delay the
surgery as long as possible,
so greater than six years.
And we want to manage their spasticity
as well as doing their surgery.
So this is a paper that we wrote,
Ros Boyd is the lead author.
And I can guarantee it's true
because we made it up in a bar one night.
And it's published, it's
published, so it's got to be true.
But it really is just a philosophy.
So when they're really
young you use Botox,
botulinum toxin, and
physical therapy and braces.
As they get older you add casting to that.
There's more casting.
And the only time we
do something different
is if their hips are coming out at any age
we put their hips back in.
And that's our philosophy.
A lot of people don't do that.
And the people who don't
do that don't see adults.
And I've had an adult
clinic for a long time now,
almost 30 years.
And I see what happens when
your hips are dislocated.
And there's no good way to
fix them once they're out,
so we put them in at any age.
And I know there'll be people in here,
I saw some people shaking
their heads already,
but we do that all the time.
And then we do this casting,
and then we do this single
event, multi-level surgery,
eight to 10 years old.
And the other thing that you
notice is when you get older
the surgery doesn't work
as well as you get older.
So there's this sweet spot, right here,
where we can intervene
and change their life.
After that it's really
salvage-type things.
So we'll go through, level 1,
these are the high-level kids.
Many of them have seizures,
they may be ASD on the spectrum,
as well as having this,
this is from my friend
Kurt Graham in Melbourne.
Very little things, these
kids may need botulinum toxin,
don't need anything else
like intrathecal baclofen,
and it's mostly a therapy kind of thing
to take care of.
And level 2, this is spastic
diplegia of prematurity.
These kids have a lot of gait problems,
and can get significant deformities,
but they don't get scoliosis,
and they rarely get hip problems.
So these are the kids,
very few of them will benefit from SDR,
but the botulinum toxin's important.
And this is where we do a lot
of our orthopedic surgery.
And this is a single
event, multi-level surgery.
These are the kids that are using braces.
And like I said, we can
have an hour-long talk
on almost every one of these slides.
Level three are the kids that
are starting to get dystonia,
so dystonia is coming into the picture.
It affects how we do the
surgery, affects on what we use.
These are the kids we might use
an intrathecal baclofen pump,
but usually it's orthopedic surgery.
We look for their hips
coming out of joint,
this is when this really starts happening.
And we start looking at their
spine at this point as well.
And so this is where we do the operations
where we cut the bones,
rotate them, put these plates,
and do these pins here.
And then level four, we're starting to see
the non-ambulatory patients.
And once again, much more dystonia,
this is the time we start
using intrathecal baclofen.
Scoliosis and hip problems
are much more prevalent
during this group, and
our surgery changes.
Before we were doing surgery
to improve their ambulation,
and now we're doing surgery
to improve their comfort and sitting.
So now we do different operations.
Before the GMFCS I guarantee
you, I've got papers,
you can look them up,
where I did operations
to get kids walking who
were GMFCS 4s at age 10.
I mean it's just stupid, you
just shouldn't even do that.
But I've got papers on it.
And some of them got better,
but almost all of them
are just sitting now.
And so once again, this
direct relationship
between hip displacement
and their GMFCS level.
90% of people GMFCS 5
will have hip problems
and need to be addressed.
And that tells you about
how you should screen them
and when you should take X-rays.
And so here, here's the
sockets not forming right,
the hips coming out of the joint.
And then we've done CT scan showing that
if you're a sitter your
hip comes out the back.
So that makes sense if you're sitting,
your muscles are pulling
your hip posteriorally.
And so we do surgery to
fix the valgus of the hip,
meaning the hips going upward.
And also for rotation, which
is femoral anteversion.
These are the operations that we do,
here's a kid with hips both out.
Here they are with the hips back in.
Another kid, same thing,
hips, here with their hips in.
Long-term follow up on that one.
So GMFCS 5s, these kids have
multiple medical comorbidities.
Almost all these kids have dystonia.
So we treat these,
90% of them will get hip
problems and scoliosis.
And our goal is comfortable sitting.
Also managing these comorbidities,
a lot of these kids get all kinds,
they're seeing all the other doctors,
the gastroenterologist, the
neurologist, pulmonologist.
And our goal is to do preventive surgery
so we don't have to do salvage procedures.
We also start thinking a lot more
of the caregiver quality of life.
We think about it all the time,
but this is really a
tough time for families
with a child with GMFCS 5.
And so we had do these
things to address the hip,
and these are all salvage procedures
that we don't want to do.
These are kids whose hips are dislocated
and no one picked them up,
and these are the things that we can do.
None of these are good.
This is a 13-year-old kid
whose hip was coming out,
there is no cartilage
on this hip left, OK.
Can you imagine how painful that would be.
So isn't this a very cool operation
where we just cut the hips out?
It's terrible, it's a terrible operation.
Total hips, you go oh, we
just put a total hip in.
Very high complication rate.
And very difficult to do,
there's a lot of complexity in doing that.
One of my friends in DuPont in Wilmington
is putting in shoulder arthroplasties in.
Because these kids are so
small that a shoulder will,
you could put a shoulder
there and that would work.
I'm getting ready to publish this study,
this is where we inject botulinum toxin
in the muscles around the hip.
And have had great results,
with pain relief for
up to up to six months.
So, it's an expensive way to treat it,
but not more expensive than
going in the operating room.
Just walking in an operating
room costs $15,000.
And so if I use 400
units of botulinum toxin,
that's $2,000 or something
like that, $3,000.
So it's much cheaper than doing surgery.
This is my son's foot
after my partners did all these
terrible operations on him.
And he had this ulcer.
And so I came in the operating room
and told them how to
do the right operation,
and that's his foot now.
So we fused the MTP joint
and we lengthened the tendon.
I'm joking about that, but no.
But his foot does look better now.
And so we fuse joints for stability.
In the spine we have all
these different deformities,
particularly things like scoliosis.
And this is my son's surgery,
here you can see is baclofen pump.
And you can see these
rods and things in there.
So this is very common
in the kids who GMFCS 5.
Now once again, I could talk in an hour
about each one of these things.
There's all these things
that are called alternative treatments
or unconventional treatments.
And I'm not going to
spend much time on them.
But a lot of these are
entrepreneurial-based,
and just because it means that
we didn't come up with them
as doctors so that means
they must be wrong.
But there might be
something to some of these,
but most of them have not been shown
to have any good long-term outcome.
Caregiver stress is an
important area to think about,
because you're not
treating just the child,
you're treating the family,
you're treating the parents.
There's a much higher
instance of back pain.
I've had three spine surgeries,
but I probably blame that on football
and being an orthopedic surgeon,
but I did lift my son a lot.
So there's a higher incidence of back pain
in parents who have kids
with cerebral palsy.
Increased mental strain.
You know there's a paper that was written
that said 85% of parents with
cerebral palsy are divorced.
And I go gosh, I just don't see that.
And then when I wrote a paper
on this caregiver stress
I found out that person just made that up
and put it in a book.
And the statistics are no
worse than regular marriage,
which is 50%, still pretty bad.
However, mothers usually
give up to their jobs
or their careers.
There're sleep disorders with the child,
there're sleep disorders with
the parents particularly.
My wife has probably not
had a good night's sleep
in 35 years.
There's sibling stress.
It's interesting if you
look at a lot of literature
on siblings, they go
into caregiving fields,
which is really interesting.
I said my son's going to be a
pediatric orthopedic surgeon,
so it's kind of interesting.
The other stress is something
that Yvonne brought up today,
is that we have all these new treatments
that are very expensive,
and we have no evidence.
And what are you supposed to do.
And I was guilty of that,
we used the selective dorsal rhizotomy.
But the stem-cell treatment
is what everybody wants now.
And people go to Mexico and
Germany and China to get these,
as you all know.
I have a whole talk on transition,
so I won't go through this.
And I won't talk about
some of the adult issues,
but I have a huge adult clinic.
And one thing I want to bring up
because I'm going to bring it up again
is that the huge mental problems
that people with cerebral palsy have.
45% of my patients have bipolar disorder.
And it's not because
they're just depressed
because they have a disability.
They actually become manic,
or they don't sleep for seven
days and are hitting out
and reaching out to people.
This is a different problem
and this is something
that we haven't haven't noticed that much.
I end with two things.
And I've been through these,
and just like when you
someone in your family dies
you go through these stages of grief,
of shock and denial.
Anger, bargaining, depression.
Testing, seeing if there's
any real realistic solution,
and finally acceptance.
And every one of our
families goes through these
at different times.
Some of them never get past anger.
And some of them get to acceptance
when the kid's two or three years old.
They go OK, this is what it is,
and this how I have to live.
So what have I learned in my 35 years?
People are seeking for
a cure for their child.
Simple insights led to
great changes in care.
Dystonia, the GMFCS.
There's almost no money
available for research,
as Marshalyn will tell you.
We went to Congress, lobbied,
you didn't get to go
because you work for them.
But we got to go, we went to Congress.
Huh?
I did, yeah, and we got $60 million.
And then it got sequestered.
And nobody knows where it is.
And Tom Harkin retired,
and so we don't have
anything, there's no money.
There's a huge disparity
between health care
for children and adults with disabilities.
Treatment's important but
as Yvonne was saying today,
prevention is the real hope.
And all of you are my heroes.
Especially those who
have no vested interest
other than taking care of this population.
So I'm gonna quit here
because I have some more
for the next time, but thank you.
(audience applauding)